TONY.
>> PARTICULARLY SCARY WHEN THE
STORMS HIT AT NIGHT, OMAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> THE U.S. IS POISED TO ENTER
THE NEXT PHASE IN THE
VACCINATION ROLLOUT.
IN THE NEXT SEVERAL DAYS
PFIZER'S CORONAVIRUS VACCINE IS
EXPECTED TO GET AUTHORIZATION
FOR USE IN CHILDREN, AS YOUNG AS
12.
MEANWHILE, THREE MORE STATES
ANNOUNCE THEY HAD WERE END MOST
OF THEIR CORONAVIRUS
RESTRICTIONS.
AND MOLA LENGHI HAS THE LATEST.
>> Reporter: A FEDERAL HEALTH
OFFICIAL TELLS CBS NEWS THAT THE
FDA WILL SOON AUTHORIZE THE USE
OF PFIZER'S VACCINE IN CHILDREN
AGES 12 TO 15.
PFIZER RECENTLY ANNOUNCED TRIAL
RESULTS SHOWING ITS VACCINE IS
AS EFFECTIVE IN THAT AGE GROUP
AS IN ADULTS.
AND STUDY PARTICIPANTS
EXPERIENCED FEW SIDE EFFECTS.
>> IT'S A SMART REOPENING.
IT'S A MEASURED REOPENING.
IT'S A PHASED REOPENING.
>> Reporter: IN CONJUNCTION WITH
NEIGHBORING STATES NEW JERSEY
AND CONNECTICUT NEW YORK
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO ANNOUNCED
HIS STATE WOULD LIFT MOST
CAPACITY LIMITS IN A LITTLE OVER
TWO WEEKS.
RESTAURANTS, RETAIL, MUSEUMS,
OFFICES EVEN NEW YORK CITY'S
BROADWAY THEATERS WILL ALL BE
ABLE TO FULLY REOPEN AS LONG AS
SPACE IS AVAILABLE TO MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SOCIAL DISTANCING.
IT WILL BE A REMARKABLE
TURNAROUND FOR A CITY THAT LOST
MORE THAN 630,000 JOBS LAST
YEAR.
AND DREW ABOUT 44 MILLION FEWER
TOURISTS.
THE RECENT GOOD NEWS MAKES THIS
RESTAURANT OWNER EXCITED FOR THE
FUTURE.
>> IT'S TREMENDOUS, YOU KNOW,
IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN
WAITING FOR SINCE THE START OF
THE PANDEMIC.
>> Reporter: IN FLORIDA,
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS TOOK
EXECUTIVE ACTION TO IMMEDIATELY
SUSPEND ANY OUTSTANDING COVID
MANDATES CITING THE WIDE
AVAILABILITY OF VACCINES.
>> I THINK FOLKS SAYING THEY
NEED TO BE POLICING PEOPLE AT
THIS POINT, IF YOU'RE SAYING
THAT, YOU REALLY ARE SAYING YOU
DON'T BELIEVE IN THE VACCINE.
>> Reporter: THE MOVE LIMITS THE
ABILITY OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ENFORCE MASK REQUIREMENTS AND
OTHER SOCIAL DISTANCING MEASURES
AND LEFT SOME OFFICIALS A LITTLE
UNEASY.
>> PANDEMIC HAS NOT GONE AWAY.
I URGE EVERYONE TO USE COMMON
SENSE.
AND FOR GOD'S SAKE, GET THAT
VACCINE.
>> Reporter: WELL, IF THE FDA
APPROVES THE VACCINE FOR USE ON
CHILDREN AGES 12 TO 15 YEARS
OLD, A PANEL WITH THE CDC, AN
ADVISORY PANEL, BUT THEN REVIEW
THE DATA BEFORE THE AGENCY
CONSIDERS ANY CHANGES TO ITS
RECOMMENDATIONS.
GAYLE, IT'S